[Music]
here in this video we will discuss about
why konchi was banished by the five
other gods of the indian and what led to
his imprisonment as well as talk a bit
about the five gods that were present in
the meeting under the great pyramids and
missing four and then the ten others
that have been imprisoned in stone so
let's get to it
the init were originally described as a
super group of egyptian gods made up of
nine deities and worship at the
heliopolis in ancient egypt but in
episode 3 when konju forced the other
gods to summon their avatars for meeting
there were only five other gods namely
osiris isis horus hathor and tuffnut
there are four more vacant seats one can
say that the avatars were not able to
come and attend but then again the
puddles for the meeting for the gods can
present themselves anywhere so why
didn't the other four gods attend well
the answer to that question came in a
scene in episode 4 when the avatar of
osiris placed the stone ushabti of the
imprisoned konju in a place along with
nine other ushabti's of other gods
so why was konchu banished by the gods
anyway in the first place and why was he
later imprisoned in stone
oh the short question is what the hell
did he do to deserve it
well moon knight has exploited the idea
that konchu is kind of like a lone wolf
among a pack of egyptian gods and in
episode 3 it finally reveals that why
that is so
in a meeting with the other gods it is
revealed that konchu might be the most
humane out of all of them which led to
him being banished he is the only one
among them all that still seem to care
about humanity and fight for what is
right even though the other gods are now
indifferent to the suffering of humans
with their reason being that humans turn
away from them a long time ago stop
worshiping them and hence they had to
abandon them all
so in the ancient past there was a great
meeting between the gods after humans
started to stop worshiping them and
found new deities especially in egypt
and the middle east with the rise of the
abrahamic fates like judaism
christianity islam and others that's the
true issue between konchu and the other
gods it is their refusal to intervene in
humanity's battles to which khonshu
really opposes the gods would satisfy
that humans had abandoned their faith in
them and deserted humanity in a petty
manner since kantu opposed this the gods
banished the moon god from the idiot to
live out his vigilante ambitions alone
after he took it upon himself to inflict
justice on those who deserved it
but there were rules in place for that
can't you or any other god mustn't
reveal the true nature of the gods or
even expose their existence thereby only
intervening with the help of avatars and
not true direct means like by using
overt foes or display of powers
so knowing all that so when konju used
his spouse to create a solar eclipse out
of nowhere the gods saw this as a break
of their rules and summoned the avatars
to a meeting to discuss the issue so
even though mark specter conscious
avatar wasn't able to convince the other
gods to imprison harrow for trying to
release ahmed into the world kanji was
still pardoned but was then later issued
an ultimatum that if he was ever to
display his powers again in view of the
human race
and expose the existence of the gods
then he would be imprisoned which of
course did happen in the end of the
episode 3 and yes conscious was put into
an ushapti stone statue by the combined
powers of the 5 other remaining gods
now we come to another important issue a
question where are the other four gods
of the idiot there were only five in the
meeting and how many other gods have
been imprisoned in the same manner
so in the opening scenes of episode 4 we
saw the avatar of osiris carrying the
newly formed sharpie of consu
and with a seemingly heavy heart place
it alongside nine other ashabtis of
other gods which means that along with
ahmed's ushabti that was found later in
the episode there are a total of 11 gods
imprisoned in stone what are the names
well i'm not really an egyptologist but
i can definitely name a few with
confidence so there's conscious of
course and ahmed and of the other nine i
can make out our
death of anubis in the top right seth on
the left of konju and apparently hover
it as well by her appearance in the end
of the episode that hippo goddess of
fertility she damned thick yo
so how did all these other gods get
themselves turned into stone well kanchu
and ahmed's reasons are known but the
nine other gods what could possibly be
their reason and how could five of them
overpower nine other gods
so yes this is all theories from here on
end i'm guessing that of course seth and
a couple of others that might have been
aiding him in his war against osiris and
horus would have been imprisoned due to
their actions
the other gods would have slowly by
slowly one by one broken their vows and
the rules of the idiot and try to
influence humanity or help them or maybe
even attack them thus forcing the nine
other gods of the indian to put them
down into stone and of course one by one
of the four missing gods of the indian
would have also done the same
which means that konchu is only the
latest of the gods to break the rules
and the vows taken during that meeting
in the ancient past
but again yes this is still a theory
anyway with that we come to the end of
it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family
but most of all smash the bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam